oh i've got no idea what i'm going to
make a video on
what should i do
oh
hello
and i have a challenge for you
i want you to create a video where you
will list the top five recurring
characters from the stargate franchise
by recurring character i mean they must
appear in at least two episodes of
stargate they cannot ever become a
regular character so you can't have
rodney became afraid
i need this in a top five and i need you
to pick your favorite
let's see how you do
challenge
delivered
well all right then top five recurring
characters from stargate welcome to
scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
[Music]
alright so in no particular order these
are my top five reoccurring characters
from stargate sg1 now let me know in the
comment section down below if you like
these recurring characters and if i fail
to mention any of your favorites
leave it down below number one
charles kowalski now charles kowalski
was one of the members of the original
team that went through the stargate two
abidos in the stargate movie and he was
present in the first two episodes of
stargate sg-1 children's of the gods
part one and part two now unfortunately
kowalski was taken over by a goal at the
end of children of the gods part two and
the following episode was uh about that
struggle between him
and the goal who had overtaken him he
was then killed which is one of my most
favorite deaths on stargate the way he
was killed i just absolutely loved the
way they used guys to stargate to get
rid of the glow all i thought it was
fantastic and then over the course of
the series returned in reoccurring roles
uh involving parallel worlds i loved the
character of kowalski and i loved how
they brought him back with parallel
earth stories my second favorite
reoccurring character would probably
have to be martouff from the uh tokra he
appeared quite a lot in stargate sg1 now
see i have a very love-hate relationship
with the togra i love the idea that
there is a faction of the gua walled and
that are against them you know against
ratokra against ra and they are fighting
the good fight um but i do think they're
a little bit pompous a little bit
obnoxious however martouff was one of
those
outliers in this where he was he wasn't
really obnoxious he wasn't really
pompous or anything like that he was
quite level-headed i absolutely loved
his character now my favorite episode or
story arc with martuf is the
relationship between him and jonah jonah
is a tow crowd that
went into samantha carter um so the
relationship between martuf and samantha
carter was quite cemented because of
that pre-existing relationship between
their two gold uh symbiotes i absolutely
loved it and i i think it added some
extra depth to the uh the whole host uh
symbiote relationship that what the host
feels or the symbiote feels the host
will also feel as well and i thought
that was really nice especially when
it's a
um
a true uh symbiosis where that where
they've become one and it's equal
partnership now speaking of the topra
another real current character that i
absolutely love would have been jacob
now jacob carter was an ex-military man
he's samantha carter's father and he had
cancer now he was going to die the topra
then offered to make him a host to a
toku symbiote and then he became the
kind of go-between um
the human relation with the tokra and
some of the stories that came out of
that with jacob
and the tokera as a whole were
absolutely fantastic and we also got to
see some real development with
samantha carter and her father as a
result of this because
had the tokra not intervened they
wouldn't have repaired some of their
broken relationship and i think that
really helped sam grow as a character as
well my fourth pick for reoccurring
character would be oma desala you could
argue that she wasn't really a
reoccurring character because you didn't
really see her that much however her
story is fantastic now i love the
ancients
i love everything about them up until
the point that they ascended after they
ascended they kind of just
left everything they left the milky way
to fend for itself and had a
strict no interference policy which
i didn't really agree with and obviously
omar dasada didn't agree with it as well
she was responsible for helping
countless people ascend
including the harthesis child the people
of abidos daniel jackson on multiple
occasions and
yes she did also help anubis ascend but
we'll we'll just gloss over that one for
a minute i love it when they bring in
the ascendant agents into a story and
she is 100 my favorite and finally my
fifth pick is going to be master
braytack master bray tech is a jafar who
trained tilk he was once first prime to
apophis he then later trained tilk who
then became first pregnant of apophis as
well and he led the rebellion against
the guard he's the one who taught hilk
that the gua would are not gods they are
false gods and they are evil without
master braytac the free jafar nation
probably would never have ever
come to be he was instrumental in
organizing plots against aguero world
against apophis in particular and he
even helped hilk on many occasions
especially with his son ryak also i just
love master bray tech as a character he
is literally as jafar's go he's one of
the best one of my favorite episodes
from stargate sg1 is the finale of
season one probably the best finale
sg1 has ever had
um in my opinion at least and there's a
conversation between jack o'neill and
master braytac where braytac is
basically explaining how they're gonna
destroy the shield generators they're
gonna have to travel down down below the
decks basically to disable the shield
generators and it's gonna take them a
while jack o'neill then just responds
with pulling out a grenade throwing it
down blowing it up
and
just showing it
how the humans would do it
grenades
now jay you did say you wanted me to
pick my absolute favorite out of that
list and i think we all know what i'm
gonna pick now based on what everything
i've just said
it's going to have to be master bray
tack yeah okay that's not a bad list at
all
so guys get in the comments and tell us
what do you think who is the best
recurring character from all of stargate
sg1 sg universe and sg atlantis and if
you are new to the youtube channel make
sure you hit like and subscribe and also
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you